hey there Facebook 22 couple here from
CBS this morning and I'm joined by a
very special guest Kevin Alaka head of
culture and trends at YouTube that's
right so we're on Facebook right now you
are you work at YouTube this is just
against all the rules and I work for a
TV company on this is a turducken we've
decided that's right because that's any
things together three things that so
it's a but it's gonna be great because
if you didn't know it's the end of the
year and at the end of the year YouTube
takes a look at the top trending videos
of 2019 that's right what's number one
this year no wait no no let's reveal it
slowly slowly okay number five started
that's good let's start at five we have
here a Gillette Super Bowl ad on
masculinity that's right that's right do
you remember this I do yeah let's see
looks a little bit masculinity is this
the best a man can get
[Music]
is it
we can't hide for you it's been going on
far too long
you can laugh at all
[Applause]
what I so you thought they were only
selling razors but in fact they're
selling change change in masculinity I
mean we've seen for four years a lot of
different major brands were kind of
starting these larger conversations and
I mean the thing that is true about a
lot of these videos that make this list
every year and that are that are very
popular is that they're things that
people don't just watch they want to
talk about they want to sort of discuss
and unpack and this was a topic and a
video that had a strong reaction a lot
of people wanted to talk about it so it
created debate on television then was
kicked over to the internet and they did
even more debate yeah but you know it
coexisted in both places which is very
common now with a lot of these big
advertisements all right number four
this one surprised me because I had
never heard of it before there's a guy
named mr. beast mm-hmm I sound like an
idiot right now people are like got a
lot of subscribers okay but mr. beast is
his name and he's got a video called I
bought everything in the store a quart
of a challenge everything that he he
buys in this video he gives to charities
got a whole army of people I'd never
heard of this guy and he's got tens of
millions of followers and this video got
tens of millions of subscribers not
followers and the video got tens of
millions of views that's right hi so
he's I mean he's really exploded in
popularity in the last two years he has
25 million subscribers that follows
channel 0.4 billion views on his videos
from the past year yeah it's pretty wild
and what he'd sort of pioneered and
really what has made him very successful
these kind of he's big he's taken his
challenge format which is existed on
YouTube for a little bit and turned it
into these big kind of like elaborate
challenge videos a lot of them can be
ultra we call ultra ultra charitable you
know where they'll be sort of have some
sort of charitable element he kicked off
this thing called team trees this year
we're a big group of people on YouTube
are trying to raise money to plant 20
million trees so he kind of takes this
this idea of these things that you would
you would never like think you'd be able
to do and and let some play out and
video in these very entertaining ways so
with 2.4 billion views of his videos in
one year does that mean one in five
people on the planet saw one of his
videos more like is it like what's going
on well so like a few is not a person
right so you have like that you because
he's 25 million subscribers he spent
lots of videos over the course of the
year you'll have lots of people who will
come back and watch each of his videos
when they come out
it's not exactly a sort of aggregate of
the number of people it's aggregate of
the number of times that people have
watched it every press play is counted
yes not when I look away and then look
back look away look back it's not of you
exactly know that that's just one single
view okay number three invest this is
surprising investigating conspiracies
with Shane Dawson it's surprising not
because people are not interested in
conspiracies they definitely are but
because when I started watching this I
had to ditch it part way through because
I realized there's an hour and a half
long that's right that's not what you
think of when you think of like a
trending video on YouTube it's true you
know I was I went back and looked at
some of our top training videos from
like 2010 I think the average length was
about three minutes that year the
average length of the videos in this on
the list this year is a half hour all
right so we're seeing this total kind of
change in sort of the types of things
that people are watching they're they're
sort of discussing online and I think a
big part of it honestly is that as we
get more sophisticated and how we
communicate with each other any digital
spaces the things that give us more to
unpack and discuss are the things that
that become trending and Shane is really
a master at creating these things that
people really want to kind of discuss
and talk about and get involved in
that's cool number two this is like an
all-time great I think Gordon Ramsay
savagely critiquing spicy hot wings
we're actually not gonna be able to play
it because there are too many f-bombs in
it yet some strong language viewer
discretion advised why do you think this
one took off well so that series is
incredibly popular it's kind of it's a
call it's called hot ones it's from a
channel called first we feast and
there's been a billion views on this
series and he has a lot of celebrities
don't shacks done it I mean it's Shia
LaBeouf lots of people have done is that
a YouTube original that's a contributor
that's that's a channel on YouTube
that's called first we feast that
produces it but they distribute it on
YouTube and it's very popular so they're
making it on their own dime it's not
like you're funding their production I
am and then these these creators are
making their their dime off an
advertising share exactly yeah they make
they sort of you know they have ads that
run in that show it's very popular and
and a lot of celebrities come on and do
it because it's like it's definitely a
great way to promote anything you've got
going on and so the most requested
person since like the start of the show
was Gordon Ramsay they're like you have
to get Gordon's down this show to
critique the wings and so they had this
very funny and and and where do you
stand on spicy wings
I can't go to the level I mean they get
they get pretty far along he's it's it's
pretty intense I can get maybe half I
can maybe do halfway okay your opinion
is not safe for TV or Internet TV the
your opinion of spicy wings yeah I mean
what sounds like I think I can i I can't
go to like the the two million level or
two thousand level of spice but I can
get alright okay number one number one
this is a big reveal if you have drums
at home play them now the big reveal
number one this is this is completely
shocking to me the number one top
trending video for 2019 on YouTube a
confessional video by beauty youtuber
and makeup artist James Charles
forty-eight million views I'd never
heard of this guy the whole conversation
is in reference to his mother I believe
well no it's not not his mother but
another beauty creator another beauty
creator is strong relationship it's
really amazing first of all as an
amazing performance is an amazing
monologue it's lawyerly in its detail
and there's like a soap opera quality to
the entire exchange the drama that's
unfolding yeah I guess that's why I got
40 million views yeah it's certainly I
mean she's gossip and sort of you know
that's sort of soap opera drama that
you're discussing has been a part of
celebrity culture forever
right but and James Charles I know you
might be someone that you're familiar
with but he's very very very popular in
line and he's big he is a modern
celebrity he's like incredibly popular
in the beauty community on YouTube has a
lot of these major emerging stars that
have really have really become more
mainstream in in their celebrity status
over the past year and so this was a a
big kind of back and forth that that he
had with another another creator but he
is it sort of speaks to I think how much
those creators have become a part of
kind of the online conversation he put
out another video this year he did you
know a beauty tutorial in Spanish and it
was the most light Beauty video on the
platform this year he's like he has that
power because of his his level of
celebrity right now so where would he go
as a talent in the absence of a world
where YouTube exists I mean he's his
skills are very unique I mean he could
do lots of things he could be a sort of
celebrity you know makeup artist he
could be you know a star on a reality TV
show or something but the truth is like
his skills are very sort of specific to
the medium that he's a master of and
using social media not just you
- but all different social media
platforms to build an audience of fans
that really care about the things that
he creates and the things he talks about
so 48 million views a lot of views no
one would dispute that but at the same
time I've definitely seen things with
more than 40 million views on YouTube so
how is a trending list different from a
most viewed list yeah so this is the
most this is the top training videos in
the United States right so they're the
ones that were the biggest here in the
US and it doesn't just look at views
which of course is one of the most
important things it looks at the
velocity of those views how quickly
things get watched as well as we look at
all the other ways that people really
interact with videos commenting liking
sharing to figure out what are the
videos that people are really talking
about so you've been doing this trip for
a while now right yeah and you come
every year and we do this kind of
segment yeah
nine years so what what are the
takeaways like what are the the magic
keys because you know people are
watching this trying to decipher what it
is it made these five trend and how can
I then copy them use them make my own
trend so like what have you learned what
do you what have you noticed about what
works on YouTube yeah well there's some
things that are not this there's some
things that have been true since you
know back when I started about why
things go viral and why people kind of
why why certain things become popular
and you know usually they're very
unexpected they're things that that
surprised us there are things that we
can participate in in some way whether
that's like making our own version
reacting talking about that gives us
something to actually interact with and
increasingly they come from people who
have built these large audiences right
so that when the video gets produced you
have a lot of people who are already
they're ready to sort of consume it so
people built these audiences over time
but there's a lot of things that have
changed as well I mean we talked about
the length of these videos and length is
not necessarily a defining factor of
popular videos but it is true that a lot
of these very popular videos are a fair
bit longer than than they then they used
to be they're also coming from people
who are pretty hard to categorize like
they don't fit a lot of our sort of
genre language or categories that we
think about for entertainment I mean
that mr. beast video that you'll watch
like what where does that fall and how
we organize you know entertainment or
where it is a beauty creator who makes a
video about their life fit in and where
does a person like Shane Dawson who
released who's up who's not a beauty
creator and releases a makeup line that
is was like incredibly beautiful while
selling this year
where does that where does that person
fit in so you have these kind of
interesting things that are playing out
in in terms of genre and categorization
and of course like I think the level and
scale of celebrity and and the ability
for people to build these audiences now
is beyond what it what it really was in
the past yeah it's really interesting
the talent presumably was always there
but there wasn't a business model an
economy that would allow it to express
itself fully yeah until now yeah
we're getting the rap apparently but but
let's do really quickly lightning round
on some of the most feed songs or most
liked creator videos number one again
mr. beast make this video the most like
video on YouTube exactly well done mr.
beast yeah most viewed video games
number one minecraft yeah probably not
maybe not a surprise no no I guess not
top music video in the u.s. Old Town
Road That's not me and that's like one
of the stories of the year in terms of
you know trending on the Internet of
sort of born of the internet thing
doesn't again doesn't fit a lot of
categories right there was a lot of
debate as a country song as a rap song
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day alright anything in closing you want
to add no I mean I think if you want to
see all the stuff that we we just went
through you can go to youtube.com slash
where you why and see those top training
videos you can go to we're gonna we got
the big rewind video that we released
every year that's coming out later today
so but Kevin thank you very much for
being here a quick reminder YouTube
doesn't work between 7:00 and 9:00 a.m.
weekdays when cBS This Morning is on
Facebook also goes dark please tune in
tomorrow I'm Tony to Coco